and welcome to incredible this is your
world isn't it man I live here literally
I'm here this is my business this is my
creative space so we we here man this is
literally my office where this is your
office yeah where I got the DJ set up
twitch you know my massage chair my
guitar uh all my books uh and then of
course right next to me I gotta have the
kids it's the nurse the nurse how many
kids can you get in there about 12 in
here 12. uh but yeah man so I think this
is where I'm this area right here I'm
constantly
this is I don't move from this during
business hours and then downstairs is
where we do hold on I gotta I gotta
point something out that I love that was
in here this picture right here
oh that's me and my mama I know but this
is almost like all of this stuff like on
my my entire family wherever it is like
all of the kids and just memories
grandfathers like it's so it's it's
really a Vibe man you know what I see
the I see the Mariah billboard and it I
just I just saw the tick tock you saw
your daughter how was that did you see
her I loved it
[Music]
to me that was epic in the sense of
where I always even said like
my daughter has the the entertainment
bug is bitter yeah she is definitely see
that connection with her and her mom is
beautiful
something I've always told I've always
told people this and they didn't
sometimes they didn't believe me I'm
like this dude's a businessman like
business hey we me and Kev got some
stuff cooking up come on now but okay so
in the hole so it's one of the bullpen
area this is kind of where you know we
just get creative y'all in here playing
ping pong like I talk about new shows
ideas flowing yeah we're both terrible
yeah we are we are terrible we also
because we're doing something else right
now okay but it's amazing that you know
you have these areas for everybody just
to come yeah that's it think and just
really have an idea because you know my
goal at here at Incredibles to create as
many platforms and opportunities for
young people yes uh content IP and then
show them the process of how how to own
it and do it on your own and even the
same thing like this right here is it's
my DJ set up that's where you know
everything from twitch to my radio show
so you're in here yeah like like oh yeah
look here we got the GoPro they got the
the drops we we doing it all so every
single day I'm popping from one room to
another with a different job one this
one job that's one job like how many
jobs you got nick uh about as many as
kids
I know Nick is tired he's been up all
night memorizing his kids names
by the way how is that that you know you
have moved from shoulder to show to show
and they keep hitting what does that say
what do you say to the folks
it's a blessing man my ego wants that
wants to talk about the noise but
explain to people that wild out is owned
by Nick Cannon yes sir and it's funny
because this is something that I
initially people didn't understand they
didn't get it they and so nobody would
invest in so I had to invest in my own
money and I I shot the pilot the first
one rounded up Kevin Hart when nobody
knew who he was yeah Cat Williams and
all of all of these people and said yo
I'ma run out of Comedy Club and we just
gonna while out and from there I took
the tape and sold it and showed it to
MTV and through that process I kept the
ownership of the IP and The Branding you
know we 20 years later uh
500 episodes later I also noticed that
a room yeah come on yeah the kids love
this room don't they of course this is
our gaming arcade and we we have fun in
here I mean obviously everybody knows
I'm a big kid I'm a gamer so we got the
gaming set up over there but it's it's
another space where creative you know I
mean so you can just come down here kind
of be created the kid the kid like you
said the kids love hanging out in here
do they yeah yeah and it's
big you know Dad's office is the
destination right they're like let's go
to Daddy's office didn't golden just had
a birthday how did he celebrate man he
turned dirty in a giant arcade you know
he wanted he's a young gamer too so we
gotta we got a semi truck that has uh
all nothing but gaming systems in it so
all his friends rode around there how do
you figure that out the timing to spend
with everybody everybody thinks it's
time management it's Energy Management
if you put because you got to get the
the once we're all aligned and the flow
is a lot easier if there's any kind of
low frequencies or dissension in it
that's what messes up the the scheduling
but if you because we just as long as
we're all on the same page and we all
got the same goal to be the best parents
we could possibly be that works and then
the scheduling is the schedule this room
the Sugar Factory baby what my partner's
at the Sugar Factory came through for
him y'all know I'm a big and I love
candy so I was like this is cool I gotta
I had to have my own candy store in the
office again the kids love it here I
mean they're so happy when they get to
come in here right yeah and it's
anything like because it's a difference
because I got like all my retro stuff
that you know we came up with like the
wax lips and all of that right but then
they got all that yeah the new the new
stuff for the kids they love the Sour
Patch Kids and the nerd clusters but so
it's funny we need to have fun and so
y'all cause look at this all the cereals
a lot of cereals every morning
so you get up in the morning you'll be
like I might as well yes Lucky Charms
and Cocoa Pebbles you know it's crazy
though you know I get here every morning
at 2am
what yeah so we'll explain so why do you
get here one I'm on a circadian clap so
okay so that means like you're supposed
to go to sleep when the Sun goes down
that's what our body tells us and then
you rise when the sun comes so that's
you when you can be your most creative
the hours from two to five are your most
creative but you don't want you don't
want to be your most tired right that's
your most creative hours so therefore I
get up at two and then you know my radio
show starts at six so I got I work out I
meditate and then I get prepared for the
show so by the time five is I'm I'm
fresh to go when do you go to bed go to
bed at like seven eight when the kids go
to bed I put the kids to bed you go to
bed
wait a minute he's got a barber shop I
mean not that I would need it now but
I'm just saying there's a barber shop
yeah you don't
we got it this is really where I kind of
get get ready for whatever I'm doing
here so the hair yeah you got a team and
all that stuff but gotta have my barber
chair kind of keep the Vibes and if I
have them he's a legit Barber chair
y'all yeah you got you gotta do it
lots of shoes anything you need
ultimately this Empire yes it becomes
theirs absolutely and I was even saying
that you know it's a blessing man like
hopefully because of what I am able to
do my kids could do whatever they want
to do and to be able to be in this
position and they want to be a nuclear
physicist I know somebody at the Ivy
League school that I could figure we
could start cultivating that now if they
want to go into the military if they
want to be artists if they want to be
actors it's a thing where we have the
capability now is meant to say whatever
let's start talking about it now so we
can help your dreams come true so
hopefully whatever it is that they want
to do that they'll be successful at it
they'll it'll be a passion it'll be real
and then they can provide for me
the beauty of it take your daddy I want
to be able to say you know the sky is
the limit you can operate on the highest
frequency at anything you want to do and
I want to invest in you and make sure
that you can you know live the dream
that you want to live all right are you
done
yeah yeah are you sure that was a real
that was the kind of like
God decides when we're done yeah but I
you know I believe I'm definitely I got
my hands full and I'm so focused I'm
locked in so you know as of right now
but you know when I'm 85 you never know
I'm like Picasso I'm dealing with
Picasso here okay I didn't understand I
get it I get it I get it I get it
[Music]